[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنني فقط كنت بحاجة إلى هواية كنت
بحاجة إلى هواية أحب دائمًا أن يكون لدي
نوع من الهواية
لأشغل نفسي عندما عدت إلى الإمارات العربية المتحدة
كنت أعمل في مصنع ووجدت
نفسي محاطًا  من خلال الأدوات
والآلات والكثير من نفايات الخشب ، لذلك قلت إنني سأفعل
شيئًا ما بها ، فأنا عازف جيتار
وقررت صنع جيتار
[موسيقى] ،
هناك مكونان لآلة وترية ،
هناك الجسم
وهناك عنق للجيتار  رقبة أنا أستخدم
خشب تم إنقاذه بحتة ، هناك عملية اختيار كبيرة
عندما أجد خردة الخشب II
اجمع جمعها لفترة
طويلة ، ربما تعرف عام أو عامين
أو ثلاثة ، ثم لدي كومة كبيرة
ثم أقضي أسابيع تعرفها بالفرز
أنواع مختلفة من الخشب ثم
تقطيعها إلى أبعاد مختلفة
للجسم ، إنها بالفعل نوعًا
ما تحتاج فقط إلى القليل من التحضير
لقطع التجاويف في الصندوق بحيث
يمكن أن تتناسب الرقبة معها إذا كنا
نتحدث عن السيجار  صندوق القيثارات
سأحصل عليها  تقوم المنصات بفصل المستوى الخشبي ، حيث
تقوم القطع المختلفة بتقطيعها جميعًا
إلى نفس الأبعاد بالضبط ، ثم
ألصقها جميعًا معًا ثم أقوم
بتقطيعها إلى شكل قياسي ، ثم
هناك مجموعة كاملة من
خطوات القطع واللصق لإنشاء
شكل  العنق ، هناك أكثر من 50 خطوة
يتم إجراؤها في صنع الغيتار
[موسيقى
] وتأتي الأوتار بعد ذلك بمجرد دخول الشبكة
إلى الجسم ، فإن
الأمر يتعلق بتثبيت
جهاز الجيتار في الإلكترونيات
إذا كان هذا هو ما تريده
[موسيقى]